and get ready to Brave a shave oh yeah
New York New York hosting its 14th
annual St baldrick's day head shaving
event in March every year you know it
comes around people come out they get
their heads shaved to help fight
Childhood Cancer it's March 18th and
it's from 10 to 6 p.m on the Brooklyn
Bridge it's open to the public and they
have celebrity head Shavers it's really
so much fun if you'd like to participate
we'll have a link to sign up on our
website lots of Tears joy and you know
they have schools that come out together
and they all get their heads shaved
raising great money for Childhood Cancer
Awareness you need to talk some of them
into it even though they want to take
Carlson they're confronted with the the
razors they're like
but then it's always for a good it's
wonderful and I'm
older and get it all
at all raising someone
for cancer research for kids love it
good program yes